bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24 heures sénat le sénat qui poursuit
aujourd'hui l'examen du projet de loi
logement de la ministre cécile duflot ce
matin les sénateurs ont voté pour la
garantie universelle des loyers et cet
après-midi le sénat a donné son feu vert
à la prolongation de la trêve hivernale
jusqu'au 31 mars
on va tout de suite retrouvé en duplex
de la tribune de presse de l'hémicycle
saveria roseq alors saveria et bien
comment s'est passé ce vote oui des
films delphine en effet le sénat a donc
voté à l'unanimité la prolongation de la
trêve hivernale
c'est un amendement déposé par la
sénatrice communiste mireille schurch un
amendement soutenu par la ministre du
logement cécile duflot et par le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques claude dilain
la sénatrice estime que le dispositif
actuel place les locataires en situation
d'inégalité devant la loi car
l'extension de la trêve était fonction
des conditions climatiques locales
elle a donc préconisé d'étendre cette
trêve de quinze jours les expulsions
locatives sont donc suspendus jusqu'au
31 mars au lieu du 15 mars
actuellement à noter delphine que les
associations ont salué ce vote des
sénateurs
merci beaucoup saveria pour vos
explications je vous propose donc tout
de suite bien de revoir l'adoption de
l'amendement de mireille schurch et on
se retrouve juste après pour
l'information du 24 heures c'est là nous
arrivons à l'article 10 avec un
amendement qui tombe et 4 mandement
discussion commune de 188 de madame
cherche 188 madame
oui merci monsieur le président cet
amendement propose de donner une durée
plus longue
à la trêve hivernale des expulsions
cette mesure inscrite dans les principes
de notre droit
depuis l'action de la vespière durant
l'hiver 54
en effet le présent article prévoit
l'extension de la trêve hivernale
lorsque les conditions climatiques
locales prévisible justifie par arrêté
du représentant de l'état dans la région
et dans la limite de la période comprise
entre le 15 octobre de chaque année et
le 31 mars de l'année suivante
nous estimons je pense avec raison que
cette mesure est fragile juridiquement
en créant une inégalité devant la loi
selon le lieu d'habitation
elle est donc susceptible à nos yeux
d'être déclarée inconstitutionnelle
comme le fut en son temps la loi brottes
au sujet du bonus malus
nous parlons en effet d'une application
différencier sur le territoire national
d'un droit à valeur constitutionnelle
celui d'avoir un toit sur sa tête
puisque la volonté politique est celle
d'étendre la vole la trêve hivernale et
nous partageons cette volonté nous
proposons par cet amendement de retirer
le caractère aléatoire climatique en
portant la trêve des expulsions
locatives de manière générale sur la
période courant du 15 octobre au 31 mars
et je défends l'amendement de repli dans
le même dans la même défense monsieur le
président nous avons donc cet amendement
de repli qui porte du la trêve du 1er
novembre au 31 mars
toute avancée même à petit pas en cette
matière constitue un progrès outre que
la trêve hivernale est une mesure pour
la dignité des hommes et des femmes et
des familles d'autres arguments peuvent
être développées allonger la trêve
hivernale c'est aussi alléger le travail
des services de police qui garderont
leur temps pour des faits de délinquance
beaucoup plus préoccupant que
l'incapacité des familles les plus
modestes à payer leur loyer et
permettent aux services sociaux à notre
avis qui au lieu de travailler dans
l'urgence à trouver un hébergement
précaire à une famille expulsée se
mobilisent
pour son accompagnement c'est donc sous
le bénéfice de ces observations que nous
vous invitons à adopter cet amendement
merci madame amendement 687 rectifié
madame lienneman monsieur bourque un
seul président madame la ministre
chers collègues comme mireille schurch
par cet amendement nous proposons
d'avancé au 15 octobre de manière
obligatoire la date de début de la trêve
hivernale et nous pensons que cette
mesure est une mesure importante pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
ces expulsions ont un provoque des
traumatismes profonds dans les familles
c'est important pour une famille d'avoir
un toit c'est un droit de l'homme qui
touche à l'humanité de la personne
lorsqu'il y à expulsion on doit faire en
sorte que tous les recours préalable
soit épuisée notamment les sursis
notamment les procédures amiables et
conciliation et vu le niveau d'exclusion
sociale du moment
il est important de d'allonger cette
trêve hivernale
voilà j'ai vu que le gouvernement et
notamment madame la ministre préparé
plusieurs milliers de places
d'hébergement en plus et je crois qu'il
faut faire notre l'adage la maxime de
l'abbé pierre qui disait quand il n'ya
plus de toit il n'y a plus le droit
merci amendement 45 rectifié monsieur
d'allier
merci monsieur le président nos
ministres qu'à un moment donné les
décisions de justice soient est exécuté
je sais pas très bien qui ici pourrait
s'y opposer pour autant effectivement il
faut essayer de faire en sorte que l
soient les moins durement ressenti
possible alors qu'on envisage dans
certaines conditions d'allonger la trêve
hivernale moi je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient
surtout si le critère sont des
conditions météorologiques difficiles
donc cet amendement vise simplement à
supprimer les deux mots local prévisible
qui à mon avis ne servent pas à grand
chose et la météo est une science assez
inexacts et donc on pourrait se
contenter effectivement de dire qu'en
cas de conditions météorologiques
particulières on peut tout à fait
décalée de 15 jours
c'est avec la commission monsieur dit
l'un alors l'assemblée nationale a
souhaité effectivement travailler sur
une prolongation de la tribune
la trêve hivernale mais sous des
conditions de météo locale et prévisible
ce qui je le reconnais est une notion un
peu un peu flou la commission a pensé
que justement on pouvait supprimer cette
conditionnalité parce qu'elle est quand
même très subjective même si on prenait
l'amendement de monsieur d'allier donc
elle a trouvé aussi que 30 jours passent
30 jours c'était beaucoup donc qu'elle a
donné un avis défavorable à la demande
d'amm charges qui prévoit 30 jours et
elle pense qu' il serait sage de passer
à quinze jours
et en ce qui concerne l'efficacité de
ces quinze jours
elle considère que l'amendement
socialiste n'est pas forcément le plus
efficace en revanche l'amendement dans
en fin d'hiver
dunham cherche par est bien meilleur et
donc nous donnons un avis favorable
l'amendement à l'amendement de repli de
madame cherche en ce qui concerne
l'amendement de monsieur d'allier il est
intéressant si aucun d'eux ne passe pas
si non il va tomber
donc je suis comme je souhaite que
l'amendement comme la commission
souhaite que l'amendement de mme à la
recherche passe je suis obligé de donner
un avis défavorable je pense qu'il va
tomber
merci à vis du gouvernement où madame la
ministre oui c'est un sujet important
vous l'avez dit les uns et les autres
dans vos interventions madame cherche
monsieur bourquin le gouvernement se
rallier à la position d'être favorable à
l'amendement numéro 190 de madame
cherche et demande le retrait des autres
amendements qui me paraît au vu de
l'expérience qu'on peut retirer sur la
situation qui nécessite l'allongement de
la durée de la trêve le plus pertinent
notamment en termes climatique il suffit
de voir à quelle date nous sommes et
qu'elle est quel est le climat et de
comparer avec ce qui s'est passé l'année
dernière de manière plus régulière nous
pensons que l'extension de la trêve au
31 mars est une bonne décision que le
gouvernement soutient la vie est donc
favorable à l'amendement 190 quant à
l'amendement de monsieur d'allier si cet
amendement 190 et adopté évidemment ça
répond à votre question c'est d'ailleurs
en partie en ayant conscience de cette
difficulté d'applications liées à cette
question de conditions climatiques que
le gouvernement soutient un amendement
plus clair qui est celui de madame
cherche le numéro 100 90 merci madame
cherche le 188e retirer oui il en est de
même pour le 687 madame monsieur
bourquin il est retiré
donc je vais mettre aux voix le 190 de
madame church qui a reçu l'avis
favorable de la commission et des
gouvernements
madame cher je voulais la parole vous
l'avez oui monsieur le président je
crois que sur ces questions de trêve dit
hivernale nous devons tous ensemble
progressé
martial bourquin a rappelé c'est un
traumatisme pour des familles d'être
expulsé je pense que nous ne sommes plus
tout à fait en 1954
je comprends le mot les deux mots trêve
hivernale s'est complètement
insupportable lorsqu'il fait très froid
mais lorsqu'il fait chaud ou moyennement
froid c'est aussi complètement
insupportables voire traumatisant pour
les familles donc je remercie l'avancé
qui est fait aujourd'hui pour élargir
les plages mais voyez-vous le mot
hivernale me gêne maintenant nous devons
progresser dans nos têtes pour arriver
enfin à ce qu'aucune à une pulsion mais
lieu dans notre pays
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 190 de madame cherche
quels sont ceux qui sont pour sur
l'adoption avis contraire je n'en vois
pas il est adopté à l'unanimité donc le
45 rectifié de monsieur d'allier tombe
l article 10 ha est donc ainsi rédigé je
vais mettre aux voix l'article 10 bis
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article 10 bis avis contraire il
est adopté après l'article 10 bis un
amendement 191 madame search
oui monsieur le président nous sommes
toujours dans le même sujet cet
amendement tend à interdire toute
expulsion locative lorsque le locataire
n'est pas en mesure d'accéder à un autre
logement par ses propres moyens et n'a
pas reçu de proposition de relogement
adapté cette disposition permettrait
d'une part d'inciter à la recherche de
solutions de relogement adaptée
lorsqu'un ménage ne peut pas ou ne peut
plus faire face au coût de son logement
et d'autre part éviter la multiplication
des expulsions locatives dont nous
venons de parler
les propriétaires ne seraient pas lésés
par la mesure puisque bien évidemment
comme la loi indique le refus de
concours de la force publique leur
permet d'obtenir une indemnisation
équivalent au loyer et aux charges du
logement ce fonds est d'ailleurs
particulièrement sous dotées madame la
ministre et ses crédits ont fondu au fil
des années je vous rappelle par ailleurs
mes chers collègues que les
prescriptions internationale en termes
de droit au logement comme le pacte
international relatif aux droits
économiques sociaux et culturels de 1966
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme ainsi que la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
directement applicable dans notre droit
ont créé l'obligation pour l'état de
garantir que personne ne peut être privé
de son logement en raison de conditions
de ressources insuffisantes
certains d'entre vous oppose à cette
mesure la décision du conseil
constitutionnel de 1998 sur la loi
d'orientation relative à la lutte contre
les expulsions
à cet égard je veux clarifier ce débat
l'inconstitutionnalité d'une telle
mesure n'est pas avéré en effet si le
conseil constitutionnel s'est fondé sur
le principe de séparation des pouvoirs
selon lequel on ne peut soumettre
l'exécution d'une décision de justice à
une diligence administrative
je vous rappelle que le droit au
logement a également valeur
constitutionnelle devant une décision du
conseil constitutionnel de 1995
les juges ont donc arbitrer entre deux
principes de même valeur en privilégiant
l'un par rapport à l'autre
d'autre part l'écriture même de cet
amendement ne soumet en rien l'exécution
d'une décision de justice à une
diligence administrative elle interdit
toute décision judiciaire en ce sens
de plus il ne faut pas sous-estimer
l'apport de la loi dalo et le rôle
qu'elle a confié à l'état par la voix
des préfets la question de
constitutionnalité se pose donc de
manière différente aujourd'hui
depuis la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme apple a par ailleurs sanctionné
l'état chypriote pour le non respect du
droit au maintien dans un logement au
nom de l'article 8 de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
le contexte juridique est donc très
différent et l'inconstitutionnalité de
la mesure que nous présentons n'est pas
avéré même si nous reconnaissons que la
bataille de fond reste celle de la
construction de logements notamment
public et du pouvoir d'achat des ménages
l'adoption de cet amendement serait à
notre avis un grand pas en avant en
faveur de la garantie d'un droit au
logement
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur mêmes charges crois que sur
tous les bancs on sait que les
expulsions c'est toujours la plus
mauvaise des solutions mais je crois
vous avez reconnu tout à l'heure que
effectivement ce projet de loi avait
deux avancées importantes dans la
prévention des expulsions a voté
l'article vite qui est déjà quelque
chose d'important mais nous aurons aussi
dans les minutes ou dans les heures qui
viennent la capex etc qui font que
l'hébergement le l'accompagnement pour
le logement etc qui font que
incontestablement ce projet de loi
concerne une belle avancée pour prévenir
les expulsions maintenant passer à une
espèce de prohibition générale posera
évidemment des problèmes
juridique j'aurai une jeune il revient
pas parce que vous les avez évoqué et je
suis loin d'être spécialiste mais je
crois aussi qu'il faudrait réfléchir à
des effets pervers qui pourrait être
inquiétant donc malheureusement pour
l'instant en tous les cas la commission
a donné un avis défavorable à votre
amendement merci à vis du gouvernement
madame la ministre
oui comme l'a dit le rapporteur madame
churchill nous avons déjà eu cette
discussion parce que l'expulsion
c'est la dernière extrémité c'est la
dernière extrémité et vous avez raison
de le dire ça plonge des familles dans
des situations extrêmement douloureuse
et aujourd'hui dans un certain nombre de
cas on est informé de cette situation au
moment où à l'issue de la procédure il
est demandé l'intervention de la force
publique dans un climat extrêmement
difficile et et pelli mais en même temps
vis-à-vis des locataires de mauvaise foi
et il en existe on nous ne pouvons pas
nous interdire d'utiliser cette
disposition qui permet aux propriétaires
de récupérer l'usagé de son bien parce
que sinon on pourrait se trouver dans
des situations et je tiens à votre
disposition certaines situations où les
locataires si on peut les appeler des
locataires profite de la bonne foi
supposé prévu au sein de la loi de 1989
et d'un certain nombre de dispositions
favorables
c'est donc tout le sens de la création
de la garantie universelle de prévenir
les expulsions et d'intervenir pour
éviter toutes ces expulsions qui sont
socialement dramatique et dont on se
rend compte qu'au moment où elles
interviennent avec 18 mois d'impayés des
10 des milliers d'euros d'impayés une
situation très bloqués en revanche il ne
faut pas s'interdire cet outil qui
permet aux propriétaires je crois de
pouvoir récupérer la jouissance de son
bien quand celui ci est occupé de
manière extrêmement désagréable et de
mauvaise foi c'est une toute petite
minorité mais cette toute petite
minorité existe donc il nous faut en
même temps protéger la majorité des dix
mille expulsions chaque année nous
devons le faire de manière résolue avec
la bulle mais d'ores et déjà il nous y
reviendrons avec toutes les dispositions
qui permettent la saisine très tôt de la
capec ce est là mais une meilleure
coordination dans son des interventions
çà c'est une évidence mais il ne faut
pas mais
enfin à cette méthode ultime
d'intervention qui permet sinon qui
pourrait créer des situations
extrêmement extrêmement bloqués donc
voilà pourquoi la position du
gouvernement est de vous demander le
retrait de votre amendement même si j'en
comprends la logique théorique
je vous le dis que de manière
opérationnelle il me semble utile de ne
pas considérer que cette le recours à
cette disposition est inenvisageable
et sinon l'avis du gouvernement sera
défavorable merci madame cherche
merci monsieur le président je crois
madame la ministre que vous n'avez pas
bien lu une autre amendement puisque
nous n'aimons pas nous ne sommes pas
encore et je le regrette à dire il faut
interdire toutes les expulsions mais
nous disons il faut interdire les
expulsions pour les personnes éprouvant
des difficultés particulières au regard
de leur patrimoine de l'insuffisance de
leurs ressources ou leurs conditions
d'existence donc on n'est pas dans les
impayés ou dans les personnes de
mauvaise foi qui ne peuvent pas faire
l'objet donc d'une procédure discussion
donc voilà les personnes qui sont
fléchés pour que nous puissions ensemble
délibéré que ces personnes-là éprouvant
des difficultés particulières on regarde
leur patrimoine et de l'insuffisance de
leurs ressources conditions d'existence
ne soient pas expulsés et donc ne sont
pas concernés les personnes de mauvaise
foi donc je regrette votre avis
défavorable et je maintiens bien sûr mon
amendement verse il est maintenant je
vais donc le métro voit quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté
article 10 l'amendement 77 tombe le 193
madame search
oui monsieur le président par cet
amendement nous reprenons une demande
des associations oeuvrant dans le
secteur du logement
la fnars le conseil consultatif des
personnes accueillies ou encore la
fondation abbé pierre
c'est donc je me fais le porte parole de
ce qu'elles nous ont expliqué je pense
que ça mérite discussion s'est elle
considère que limiter la saisine des
capex au seul bailleur personnes morales
n'apportera pas d'amélioration de la
prévention des expulsions locatives dans
le parc privé
là où elle est pourtant la plus
nécessaire car la plus lacunaire en
effet le présent article impose
simplement aux bailleurs personnes
physiques
un signalement obligatoire des impayés
capex et non une saisine en bonne et due
forme
pourtant de nombreux bailleurs font
jouer la clause résolutoire du bail dès
la constitution d'impayés conduisant
ainsi inéluctablement à la résiliation
du bail la logique doit à notre avis
être inversé le présent amendement
permet ainsi d'anticiper sur le
contentieux locatifs et l'expulsion sans
allonger les délais de procédure
plus la situation des ménages et examine
en amont mais là je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord plus elle a de chances
d'évoluer ainsi les démarches destiné au
remboursement de la dette locative et
celle destinée au relogement des
occupants qui n'a plus les moyens de se
maintenir dans ce logement pourront être
engagés plutôt qu'elles ne le sont
aujourd'hui tu en profites des
occupantes du bailleur qui recouvrira sa
dette et récupérera son logement dans un
délai raisonnable en outre le dispositif
proposé par le projet de loi vise
principalement les bailleurs sociaux et
remplace celui parlé prévues par les
articles l 351 3 et l 442 du code de la
construction et de l'habitation supprimé
par le grand 2 de l'article 10 il est
donc destiné à actualiser ses articles
il prévoyait une saisine obligatoire de
la commission chargée de prévenir la
suspension des aides au logement trois
mâts trois mois avant l'assignation
il convient de ne pas régresser sur ce
point de préserver ce délai de trois
mois voilà les considérants de cet
amendement dont l'adoption est attendu
par les
association merci yahvé de la commission
monsieur dit l'un la commission comment
je pense qu'il faut mieux rester au
système actuel en groupes cotés personne
morale saisissez les personnes physiques
signal pour faire un résumé c'est parce
que on risque effectivement un
engorgement pervers si je puis dire de
la commission cela dit donc il ya un
avis défavorable de la commission cela
dit je pense que vous soulevez un vrai
problème et je pense qu'il faudra qu on
en reparle
peut-être d'ici la navette parce que la
saisine est quand même importante comme
vous l'avez dit donc la commission
souhaite pour l'instant s'en tenir aux
textes parce que il faut quand même
évaluer les conséquences d'une saisine
des par les personnes physiques mais
c'est vrai qu'elle va plutôt aussi dans
votre sens mais pour l'instant elle a
donné un avis défavorable mais souhaite
rentrer travailler alors comme il ya le
groupe de travail qui s'est institué je
crois que ça fera partie des des thèmes
de réflexion et à vis du gouvernement
madame la ministre
oui ma réponse peut aller dans un champ
un peu technique et là aussi nous avons
eu des échanges mais ce qui est plus
important pour nous c'est que la saisine
de la capec ce ne soit pas une
substitution de l'assignation et qu'elle
ne peut pas reposer uniquement sur le
sur le bailleur privé les dispositions
qui existent pour les bailleurs
institutionnels afin peuvent être des
dispositions plus complexes facilement
mises en oeuvre par des bailleurs
institutionnels ça n'est pas le cas pour
des personnes physiques des bailleurs
qui ont un seul bien donc il nous semble
que le dispositif de signalement tel
qu'il est prévu dans le projet de loi
est équilibrée parce que il
permet à la fois d'avoir un signalement
précoce auprès de la capec ce mais de ne
pas entraver la procédure si l'aube
lille à la saisie de la capec ce n'a pas
été fait ce que sous-tend votre votre
amendement donc je souhaite le le
retrait de cet amendement est sinon j'y
serais défavorable
merci madame cherche madame monsieur le
président je pense qu'en effet on est
dans un sujet important mais que
peut-être il est prématuré de le de le
discuter tout de suite au fond donc je
vais me retirer en abondant et en
écoutant ce que vient de me dire le
rapporteur c'est à dire qu'il fera
l'objet d'une discussion plus
approfondie au sein du groupe de travail
car je pense que les associations
demandent quand même qu'on améliore le
la procédure merci l'amendement est donc
retiré
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale pour l'accès au logement et à
un urbanisme rénové dans la discussion
des articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement numéro 75 rectifié bis au
sein de l'article 10 et je suis saisie
de quatre amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune
le premier amendement 75 rectifié bis et
présentée par monsieur dubois non à
monsieur marseille pardon
le président madame la ministre
actuellement l'article 1940 4-1 du code
civil permet au juge d'accorder des
délais de paiement pouvant aller jusqu'à
deux ans avec pour critères la situation
du débiteur et considération des besoins
du créancier
le texte du projet porte ce délai à
trois ans pour les délais de paiement et
la suspension des procédures d'exécution
prévue par l'article tout 140 4-2 qui
tiendra à rendre quasiment impossible
tout remboursement des sommes dues et
toute expulsion
c'est donc l'objet de se présente
amendement bien je vous remercie chaque
collègue qui présente 349 rectifié
monsieur d'allier oui monsieur le
président vous l'avez écouté c'est
quasiment le même objet à hal malines et
après donc on va considérer qu'il est
défendu bien le 573 rectifié tombe et il
ne reste donc le 76 rectifié qui est
présentée par monsieur dubois au
monsieur marseille il est défendu
il a défendu bien quel est l'avis de la
commission sur ces quatre amendements
cetc initialement 4 24 amendements ont
un point commun très nette s'agit de
revenir sur une des avancées du projet
de loi en matière de délais de paiement
je tiens quand même à préciser que pour
qu'ils fassent d'ambiguïté que ces trois
ans au maximum c'est à dire qu'il faut
pas laisser entendre que le juge doit
décréter trois ans il peut décréter
nettement moins deuxièmement
ça c'est sur la forme sur le fond toutes
les associations où une grande partie
des associations
on l'a vu ça dans le loi de la loi sur
la consommation ce hostile au fait de
raccourcir les délais de paiement parce
que ça rend leur l'épurement l'apurement
de la dette moins efficace donc la
commission pense donne un avis
défavorable sur les trois amendements
qui reste monsieur le président quel est
l'avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
exactement identique à celui du
rapporteur et pour les mêmes raisons je
prends ton 2 bien bien
donc s'il n'y a pas de demande
d'explications de vote donc je vais si
monsieur dubois la parole d'un ministre
madame la ministre je vous ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention à la fin de la
matinée
quand vous avez répondu madame charge et
vous lui avez finalement expliqué que
l'on allait mettre en place un système
solidaire mutualiste qu'est la gueule et
que à partir de là finalement il fallait
retirer votre amendement qui était
extrêmement protecteurs vrai dans le
cadre de l'expulsion et la cie voulait à
travers le l'amendement que nous
déposons on est à la limite un peu dans
le même système
moi j'ai tendance à dire un autre groupe
l'a démontré ce matin oui à la
solidarité
oui à la mutualisation ray pour faire en
sorte que les locataires de bonne foi
soient protégés mais d'un autre côté si
l'on veut que ça fonctionne
si on veut qu'il y ait réellement un
équilibre il faut que de l'autre côté
les droits du locataire soit très limité
faute de quoi devrait on va vers un
système où le curseur est toujours placé
du même côté et va déséquilibrer le
système puisque encore une fois la bulle
va faire en sorte que normalement tous
locataires de bonne foi qui sera dans
une difficulté pour payer son loyer ont
valu régler le problème il ne restera
donc plus normalement que les locataires
de mauvaise foi ou alors je comprend pas
le système
alors oui à la mutualisation mais non à
des droits exponentielle en faveur des
locataires qui serait de mauvaise foi et
tout le débat est sur le placement du
curseur voilà la raison pour lesquelles
nous avons déposé cet amendement bien
c'est toujours dans le même sens le
rapporteur madame la mine et se
souhaiter intervenir
il savait la parole vous faites une
erreur
monsieur dubois parce que ça n'est pas
automatique pas du tout non non non pas
du tout mais ça n'est pas automatique il
s'agit d'une décision judiciaire
il s'agit d'une décision judiciaire et
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas avoir une
durée de recouvrement qui soit
de trois ans donc la prise de ce type de
décision est de nature à permettre au
bailleur d'apurer sa dette et d'être
remboursé et d'ailleurs si jamais le
plan d'apurement décidé judiciairement
n'est pas appliqué la procédure va à son
terme c'est à dire que comme il s'agit
pas d'une décision de dames accord de
gré à gré mais bien d'une décision prise
par le juge celle-ci s'impose et la
rupture de cette décision conduit à
l'expulsion
ça va recommencer donc je pense que pour
aller dans le sens que vous souhaitez
c'est à dire que les impayés soit pays
il faut que la décision de justice
puisse s'exécuter et pour ça elle
il est utile qu'elle puisse prendre une
durée plus longue pour être plus
efficace bien monsieur d'alliés pour
l'explication de vote
monsieur le président madame le ministre
il y a quand même quelque chose de
paradoxal au fait d'affirmer et c'est
une bonne chose qu'on veut essayer de
prévenir les expulsions et donc essayer
de prendre le plus en amont possible les
impayés c'est le but effectivement des
mécanismes dont nous discutons alors la
gueule d'un côté et dans j'allais dire
vis-à-vis du secteur public
les bailleurs publics doivent
effectivement mettre en place un
dispositif qui vise à prévenir
effectivement les situations d'impayés
et de l'autre côté aja rallonger les
délais de paiement tiers c'est comme si
en fait on ne croyait pas à l'efficacité
de ce dont on est en train de discuter
voilà donc moi ça me paraît un peu un
peu paradoxal
bien donc je vais mettre aux voix donc
cet amendement 75 rectifié bis qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient ne pas
adopter n'aurions 349 rectifié qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le sas je vivais parti
et le 76 rectifié même même vote même
bottes il n'est pas adopté nous en
venons au à l'amendement 509 qui est
présenté par le gouvernement au madame
la ministre
oui monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
l'objectif de cet amendement est de
codifier dans le code de la construction
et de l'habitation
une partie des dispositions relatives au
surendettement introduite par le vote de
la loi de séparation et de régulation
des activités bancaires promulguée le 27
juillet 2013 afin d'améliorer leur
lisibilité pour ce qui concerne les
aides personnalisées au logement il
s'agit donc d'une traduction des
dispositions que vous avez d'une
codification des dispositions que vous
avez déjà adopté quel est l'avis de la
commission la commission donne un avis
favorable à cette clarification
je n'ai pas d'explications de vote de
demande d'explication note bien donc je
vais mettre aux voix
cet amendement numéro 509 qui est pour
cet amendement qui compte
il s'abstient l'amendement est adopté
nous en venons à deux amendements
identiques à l'article 10 toujours le
premier est présenté par madame cherche
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à prévenir la
dégradation des incidents de paiement et
les situations d'expulsion dans le parc
hlm
en effet la loi de programmation pour la
cohésion sociale de 2005 prévoit la
possibilité de signer un protocole
d'accord entre le bailleur et le
locataire en vue de prévenir les
expulsions et dans ce protocole il est
prévu l'engagement du locataire à
respecter le plan d'apurement de la
dette
d'une part et l'engagement du bailleur a
renoncé à la poursuite de la procédure
d'expulsion
si le protocole est respecté par cet
amendement
nous proposons que soit intégrée dans ce
protocole
l'examen par le bailleur de possibilité
de proposer aux locataires une
permutation vers un logement plus adapté
en termes de montants de loyers tout en
en tenant compte bien sûr de la
typologie du ménage il s'agit ainsi vous
l'aurez compris de permettre que
l'ensemble des facultés soit consacré
législativement pour permettre une
résolution la plus facile et la plus
amiable des litiges liés aux impayés
il convient ainsi de permettre que
l'organisme hlm ne se prive pas de la
possibilité de reloger le ménage endetté
dans un logement éventuellement plus
petit ou plus anciens ou en tout cas
moins onéreux pour faciliter la
réduction de la dette locative
existantes
un tel amendement permet également de
faciliter la mobilité locative
et je pense que c'est monsieur l'abbé
donc qui présente le 425 rectifié même
amendement même argumentaire de défense
donc tout simplement cet amendement
propose que soit intégrée dans ce
protocole la possibilité pour le
bailleur de proposer aux locataires une
mutation vers un logement plus adapté en
termes de montants de l'eau liées de
loyer par an tout en tenant compte de la
spécificité de chaque ménage et cela
dans le but évidemment d'éviter au
maximum lé situation d'expulsion dans le
parc hlm je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
ces deux amendements même cherché et de
monsieur l'abbé qui sont identiques sont
des amendements de bon sens puisque si
on veut que le débiteur règle sa dette
il faut pas lui donner un loyer encore
plus élevé parce que sinon ce serait
complètement contre-productif dont
l'idée que l'idée que l'idée qu' on
essaye d'adapter un logement avec un
loyer qu'ils soient moins faisant pour
pour les revenus de du débiteur me
paraît une bonne chose donc la
commission a donné un avis favorable aux
deux vient donc quel est l'avis de
madame la ministre après le gouvernement
oui l'avis du gouvernement est favorable
puisque proposer une mutation c'est à
dire ne pas considérer que empêcher
l'expulsion c'est maintenir dans un
logement notamment dans un logement dont
le niveau de loyer est manifestement
inadaptées au niveau de revenus du
locataire c'est une bonne solution donc
je suis favorable à l'amendement de
madame cher châssis qu'est celui de
monsieur l'abbé qui sont similaires
il ya pour explication de vote monsieur
collombat parole très franchement je me
demande pour pour quel lieu ou non lieu
on légifère est ce qu'on légifère pour
le paradis où on légifère pour la
réalité
vous allez les mettre où les gens veut
dire on n'allait pas ça va être un peu
comme pour le dalo quoi au niveau des
principes c'est excellent on peut pas
rêver mieux
la bureaucratie mise à part
mais dans la réalité ça veut dire quoi à
part faire des logements
je vois pas ce que ce genre de
disposition changera à la réalité
monsieur d'allier vous avez demandé la
parole pour rester qu'à son de vote
également mais je serai moins sévère que
notre collègue collombat mais à partir
du moment où on est dans l'ordre des
possibilités à quoi cela sert-il
d'inscrire cela dans la loi enfin un
bailleur normalement constitué peut
effectivement cherché à trouver une
solution en proposant aux ménages
surendettés un logement plus petit avec
un loyer adapté là enfin on dit que la
loi et verbeuse mais excusez moi on est
dans les dents les bonnes intentions
mais aujourd'hui rien n'empêche un
bailleur un bailleur social de se
comporter ainsi
donc là vous l'écrivez dans la loi alors
si on doit mettre dans la loi tout ce
que l'on peut faire qui n'est pas
interdit par la loi
on avait les codes n'ont pas fini de
voir jaillir leur épaisseur augmenté oui
monsieur dubois pour explication de vote
oui non moi je quand je lis ça je me
demande à quoi servent les commissions
de prévention des expulsions dans les
organismes hlm mais je me demande si
vous connaissez je dirais le
fonctionnement des commissions de
prévention des expulsions dans les
organismes hlm
est ce que vous êtes déjà allé dans les
commissions de prévention des expulsions
des hlm est-ce que vous avez déjà prête
mais à côté je me je m'excuse mais quand
je lis ça je me pose vraiment la
question parce que c'est le type de
débat qu'effectivement gérer dans les
commissions de prévention des expulsions
des hlm
nous avons nous avons effectivement face
à une situation difficile
quel type de solution rend pas à porter
et ensuite quel type de logement mieux
adapté on peut proposer à la famille
c'est tellement évident c'est tellement
évident que effectivement vrai comme
ceux colombes à gérer les bras m'en
tombent
je sais ce monsieur l'abbé vous
souhaitez tout simplement pour y
répondre c'est que c'est si ces sites et
vite si évident et qu'on ait besoin de
l'écrire c'est qu'il y a des cas comme
cela et qui a nécessité de véritablement
regarder pour des logements qu'ils
soient adaptés et dans l'intérêt des est
dans l'intérêt des ménages est ce que je
trouve regrettable sur un sujet comme ça
c'est de sentir une espèce d'agressivité
là qui n'a vraiment pas lieu d'être
madame cherche pour explication de vote
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues c'est monsieur collomb bac est
à madame cherche ses boucles oui
franchement je pensais que c'est un
amendement de bon sens on mérite
d'écrire dans la loi parce qu'on nous le
demande ça veut dire que c'est pas
toujours aussi rose
excusez moi et donc voilà nous l'acte on
ne le consacrons dans la loi points et
donc vous allez voter parce que c'est un
amendement de bon sens évidemment je
vais donc mettre aux voix
ces deux amendements qui est pour et qui
est contre
qui s'abstient les amendements sont
adoptés
j'en viens maintenant à l'amendement 776
qui est présentée par monsieur dit l'un
au nom de la commission des affaires
économiques simples amendements de
coordination sur président madame la
ministre
favorable je mets au voile amendement
776 qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
nous en venons maintenant à l'amendement
574 rectifié qui est présentée par
monsieur mézard
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre et chers collègues il s'agit
d'amendements qui est dans le jir aidant
dans la ligne des amendements qui
viennent d'être examiné il ya cinq
minutes relatif à l'article 12 140 4-1
du code civil là il s'agit de remplacer
le mot trois ans par deux en ce qui
concerne l'application de l'article l
412 4 du code des procédures civiles
d'exécution
cet article permet au juge qui est
essentiellement le juge d'instance tout
cas le juge civil le plus souvent le
juge d'instance et parfois le juge des
référés d'accorder des délais dit délai
de grâce aux occupants de locaux dont
l'expulsion a été ordonnée
judiciairement chaque fois que le
relogement des intéressés ne peut avoir
lieu dans des conditions normales ces
délais sont d'un an renouvelable
un amendement voté par l'assemblée
nationale donc il ne figurait pas dans
le texte initial du gouvernement va
porter ses délais à trois ans et le
l'estimons parce que c'est comme sur les
délais de l'article 12 144 faut quand
même connaître la pratique quand on est
devant un tribunal d'instance et voir
comment ça fonctionne bon c'est pas en
augmentant ses délais là que vous allez
résoudre les problèmes vous allait
aggraver la situation
faut se mettre il faut se mettre à la
place ce que vous vivez ça avec 2
de grandes sociétés propriétaires de
dizaines voire de centaines
d'appartements qui effectivement non pas
être protégé mais le bailleur qui a un
appartement qui loue et qui se trouvent
dans ces situations là pour lequel c'est
un complément de revenu que fait-il
ensuite nous nous estimons que ce n'est
pas aux propriétaires de supporter les
lenteurs des délais de procédure et de
relogement du aux banques de logements
sociaux dans la construction incombe à
l'état et aux collectivités et donc il
s'agit de revenir à l'équilibré qui
existe et qui existait avec un délai de
deux ans qui est plus raisonnable pour
le propriétaire est moins
déresponsabilisant pour les acteurs du
logement social sachant en outre que il
faut pas confondre les procédures de
surendettement les procédures de
résiliation et d'expulsion et vie et
maintenant l'application de la garantie
universelle loyer ce sont trois choses
complémentaires mais différente et on
mélange systématiquement les choses ce
qui fait que loin loin de crédibiliser
le système vous allez mettre en place
des solutions qui vont mettre les
bailleurs et en particulier les
bailleurs qui sont privées qui n'ont
qu'un appartement dans des situations
encore plus difficile parce que quand il
faut dans ces cas-là récupérer là on
expliquera comment la gueule
fonctionnera dans ces cas là est ce que
la bulle paiera je ne le crois pas moi
et dans ces cas là il faut faire quoi il
faut faire une action devant le tribunal
administratif contre l'état pour
récupérer avec croyez moi il y en a peu
qu'ils font et c'est particulièrement
long et difficultueux pour arriver à
récupérer les sommes qui sont dues aux
bailleurs donc ce n'est pas l' équilibre
bien quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur del un monsieur mais ça je vous
ai entendu et et vous avez raison et il
ya des situations où donner un délai de
trois ans paraît complètement stupide
mais une fois de plus le fait d'allonger
la possibilité du délai ne veut pas dire
qu'il va s'appliquer dans toutes les
situations parce qu'elles sont
extrêmement diversifiée
monsieur le président mais art et s'il
ya des situations où trois ans paraît
complètement vous paraît en tout les cas
complètement ahurissant il peut y avoir
des situations où trois ans peut être
une bonne solution
simplement les sons au juge la
possibilité c'est tout j'ai bien compris
j'ai bien compris que pour trois ans
pour certaines situations d'accord je ne
nie pas c'est simplement la loi dit
donnons cette possibilité au juge qu'il
apprendra ou qu'il apprendra pas je
donne un avis défavorable
quel est l'avis de madame la ministre
le gouvernement identique à celui du
rapporteur monsieur le président bien
monsieur ménard souhaite intervenir
prestation de vote
oui parce que on nous dit mais c'est le
juge aura eu une possibilité et
d'accorder des délais supplémentaires
mais alors dans ce cas là dit au juge
qu' il pourra accorder tous les des
lignes dont il a envie à chaque fois ce
sera trois ans vous mettriez en face une
solution automatique pour que le
bailleur puisse obtenir une compensation
de ses pertes
la question serait différente mais vous
savez vous ne pouvez pas ignorer que la
seule véritable solution dans ces cas là
c'est saisir le juge administratif et on
veut pas le dire parce que ici on vit je
n'ose pas dire qu'on serait pas ici en
tout cas mais dans ceux qui pompe ce
genre de textes chez les bisounours la
réalité judiciaire elle est différente
nous avons trois types de procédures qui
s'entrechoquent et et vous allez
peut-être en faire d'autres
vous avez à la fois les questions de
surendettement jeu l'éditeur à la fois
les la procédure normale de résiliation
expulsion dans les tribunaux d'instance
et en plus
effectivement dans certains cas
l'impérieuse nécessité de saisir le
tribunal administratif
monsieur le rapporteur si vous êtes le
propriétaire qui n'accueille qu'un
logement qui est pour lui un complément
de revenus ou de retraite
vous vous rendez compte la situation
alors si vous voulez accorder des délais
supplémentaires venir et aux frais de
ces gens là et bien mettez en face les
moyens soient d'accélérer les procédures
pour récupérer pour récupérer les
impayés soit d'autre solution judiciaire
mais là vous allez à l'encontre vous
savez le bailleur intervient et par là
monsieur présent le bailleur qui s'est
fait pincer une fois de cette manière là
croyez bien un qui préfère garder son
logement vacant voilà la réalité la
réalité de terrain bien la parole est à
monsieur dubois pour explications de
vote le ministre moi je voudrais en
profiter pour remercier vrai le
président mézard parce qu'il me donne
l'occasion de reparler de l'amendement
75 rectifié bis parce que c'est le même
état d'esprit
c'est exactement le même état d'esprit
en tant que conseiller général lors de
mes permanences
il m'arrive de rencontrer j'aurai des
instituteurs des petits temples des
petits employés virés etc qui sont
propriétaires d'un logement et qu'ils
sont démunis quand il se trouve
confronté à un locataire qui ne payent
pas leur loyer alors que eux ont un
emprunt à rembourser est effectivement
gérer on n'est pas face à des
propriétaires de 100 200 logements
on est face à des petits propriétaires
entre guillemets qui ont simplement
décidé d'acheter un logement mais pour
faire en sorte degré d'assurer une
retraite un peu meilleur vrai quand ils
le seront en retraite voilà tout
simplement et avec les dispositifs que
vous prévoyez et bien vous amènerait
aurait tout simplement ses propriétaires
à ne plus relou est vrai quand ils
seront sortis j'aurais de l'impasse dans
laquelle vous donner les maîtres ou qui
surtout ou qui surtout n'achèteront plus
de logements n'investiront plus dans le
logement
et l'on sait tous et toutes que si les
investisseurs ne sont pas au rendez vous
pour construire de nouveaux logements
nous n'atteindrons jamais les cinq cent
mille logements et surtout nous
n'augmenterons pas l'offre de logements
7 contre productive vos propositions
c'est contre-productif et déséquilibré
monsieur le noir pour l'explication de
vote
le président madame et mintya collègues
excellentes interventions des deux prêts
opinant me dispense d'en dire beaucoup
plus nous souffrirons complètement ce
que vous avez dit effet pour laquelle le
groupe ump demandent à scrutin public
sur cet amendement
bien je n'ai pas d'autres interventions
donc je suis effectivement saisi d'un
demandes de scrutins publics de la part
du groupe ump sur l'amendement 574
rectifier je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable et qu'il va
donc être procédé à ce que d'un public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
donc le scrutin est ouvert
je
et les prix
g
jean bigot visées civiles
plus personne demande à voter donc le
scrutin est clos
j'invite les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
parce que
je me vois obligé la paix alors dans
monsieur le l'ancien président du sénat
oui
chers collègues voici le résultat du
scrutin numéro 26 sur l'amendement
numéro 574 rectifier à l'article 10 du
projet de loi
nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 345 pour l'adoption
187 contre 158 le sénat a adopté un
amendement
je vais donc mettre au voir maintenant
l'article 10 tel qu'il est amendée qui
est pour article 10 qui est contre qui
s'abstient à l'article 10 est adopté
nous en venons à l'article 11 où j'ai un
amendement 701 qui est présenté par
madame lindemann
oui madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
c'est un amendement qui est plutôt un
amendement d'appel parce qu'en fait de
nous observons sur le terrain un
décalage entre les délais qui sont
utilisées quand il ya une mesure
d'expulsion ou quand on doit mettre en
place une procédure d'expulsion et le
fait que la commission alors supposons
même que à ce moment là on prévient la
commission dalo elle a six mois pour
réagir d'après dans les décrets
or le il ya trois mois pour pouvoir
expulser la personne donc la coïncidence
des délais entre le déclenchement de la
saisine de la commission dalo et la
saisine et la mise en oeuvre des
expulsions ne coïncident pas on a deux
solutions soit comme je lé proposées
dans l'amendement c'est quand même
plutôt l'artillerie lourde c'est à dire
on suspend la mise en oeuvre de
l'exécution en attendant le dalo
franchement c'est pas la meilleure
solution
l'autre solution mais dépend quand même
du ministre puisqu'on est dans le
règlement on est dans un décret c'est de
faire que pour au moins ces cas là les
délais de la commission dalo pour
statuer soit raccourci
pour qu'on n'ait pas tamponnage
d'échéancier donc c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles madame la ministre je
suis prête à retirer cet amendement
souhaitant que vous même vous puissiez
nous indiquer le souci de vos services
de rendre compatibles ses délais et
d'autre part je soutiendrai l'amendement
550 avec le groupe socialiste de madame
cherche
monsieur le rapporteur que de l'avis de
la commission
mais madame lienemann vous avez parlé
d'artillerie lourde la commission on
partage votre avis et souhaite le
retrait est effectivement au bénéfice
d'un ralliement aux 550 que nous allons
étudier mais plus tard parce que je
crois que ces articles 18 bien madame la
ministre
quel est votre avis sur cet amendement
vous avez dit l'artillerie lourde
je vous propose un mode plus léger et
donc le retrait de votre amendement
lourd au profit de l'amendement 550 qui
vient bien plus tard dans la discussion
bien madame lienemann que retrait je
vous remercie d'amendement est retiré
nous en venons maintenant ou à
l'amendement 774 présentée par monsieur
dit l'un au nom de la commission des
affaires économiques de coordination
amendement une coordination favorable
qui est pour cet amendement qui et
contre qui s'abstient l'amendement est
adopté
nous allons par conséquent voter sur
l'article 11 ainsi amendée qui est pour
et contre qui s'abstient l'article 11 et
adopter le passant l'article 11 bis avec
une prise de parole de madame cherche
oui monsieur le président le présent
article a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale sur l'initiative du groupe
socialiste en commission il vise à ce
que le gouvernement remette au parlement
avant la fin de l'année 2014 un rapport
sur les modalités de calcul du montant
de l'apl prenant en compte la moyenne
des ressources perçues au cours des
trois derniers mois précédant la demande
madame la ministre vous avez été
favorable à cette mesure en effet vous
avez estimé que de nombreux ménages
souffrait du mode de calcul de l'apl
fondé actuellement sur les revenus de
l'année n - 2 c'est à dire complètement
déconnecté de la réalité de la situation
nous souscrivons évidemment à la
réalisation de ce rapport
cependant mes chers collègues puisqu'il
est question ici d'apl je vois bien
d'autres sujets d'inquiétude qui devrait
appeler des engagements fermes de la
part du gouvernement afin de clarifier
sa ligne en faveur du renforcement du
pouvoir d'achat je pense notamment à la
nécessité de revenir sur la non
rétroactivité des apl adopter lorsque la
droite était au pouvoir
nous pensons effectivement et en
partageant l'objectif du présent article
qu'il est nécessaire que les apl qu'ils
sont